eo la gauche ah non maintenant de la
présidentielle y at il un sursaut à
gauche derrière une éventuelle
candidature de françois hollande au
débat est ouvert en direct dans le
studio juste à côté
c'est là qu'on retrouve tout de suite
eric sicaud en direct avec ses invités
merci emmanuel oui on parle plus
globalement pendant cette émission du
coût de la défiance vis-à-vis de la
classe politique avec yves quemener de
nous citoyens laurent grandguillaume
pour le parti socialiste
jean-baptiste lemoyne pour les
républicains il y en a marre ou pour le
front national chose promise chose due
je vous redonne la parole monsieur pena
avec une question d'un internaute qui
nous dit et si vous deviez changer un
seul truc de fonds ce serait quoi
il fonctionne ça tombe bien partir en
fait les solutions tout le monde les a
depuis une trentaine d'années vous
reprenez tous les tous les rapports qui
ont été faits les bouquins qui ont été
faits récemment le bouquin de laurent
grandguillaume les réponses on les
connaît par contre ce qu'il ce qu'il
manquait pour répondre à votre à votre
internaute s'est il faut préalablement
déverrouiller le déverrouiller des
systèmes et de notre point de vue il ya
quatre verrous important à déverrouiller
le verrou institutionnels non cumul des
mandats
demanda consécutifs maximum de notre
point de vue une modification du statut
du chef de l'état c'est à dire pour
repasser un septennat
mais à septennat unique pas de pas de
réélection deuxième deuxième verrou ce
verrou territoriales parce que même si
la loi notre a fait de bonnes choses
il ya quand même beaucoup à beaucoup à
améliorer pour réduire le millefeuille
administratif entre entre l'europe et
puis une commune de 2 500 habitants
troisième verrous c'est le verrou
sociale et on le voit bien avec avec la
loi la loi travail on vit depuis 50 ans
avec des partenaires sociaux qui n'ont
pas évolué la preuve 8 % des 8 % des
salariés sont syndiqués
ça prouve bien qu'il ne réponde pas à la
tente des halles attentes des salariés
la défiance est également vis-à-vis des
syndicats savent eux que ça veut dire
ex faire éclater le paritarisme
mais pour plus de paritarisme
c'est à dire ouvrir les syndics ouvrir
les ouvrir le la syndicalisation à tout
le monde
84e verrou c'est le verrou c'est le
verrou économique et qu'on arrête de
d'embêter les chefs d'entreprise on vous
voulez des êtres vous voulez des
subventions les cinq entreprises ne
veulent pas d'être les chefs
d'entreprise ne veulent pas de
subventions les chefs d'entreprise ne
veulent pas de baisse des charges
particulièrement les entreprises et sur
balles arrêtées
non non non les angles des chefs
d'entreprise de pme
moi je parle pas des deux du cac 40 les
chefs d'entreprise du pdd des pme qu'est
ce qu'ils veulent
lâchez-nous les baskets laissez nous
laissez nous travailler et y ont la plus
grande liberté possible avec nous avec
nos collaborateurs pour agir et c'est à
partir de celui de la partir de ces
quatre verrous c4 c4 cadenas qu'on aura
tâche et qu'on pourra effectivement
rentré dans les rentrées dans les
réformes de alors est ce qu'on est prêt
à caracas et séquelles on a dans les
partis politiques
j'aurais six mois moi je crois qu'il
faut aller effectivement sur les mesures
concrètes maintenant donc il faut
absolument arriver à légiférer mieux et
vite mieux ça veut dire effectivement
avoir dans les administrations centrales
aussi des gens qui sont issus de la
vraie vie moi ça me choquerait pas qu'on
dise un directeur d'administration
centrale
il faut pas seulement qu'il ait fait
l'ena ou quoi que ce soit et ça peut
être quelqu'un qui est issu du privé qui
fait une mission de deux ans de trois
ans pour que véritablement une
respiration premier point pour légiférer
mieux parce qu'en fait on sait 90% des
lois ok elles sont votées mais elles
sont proposées par le gouvernement et
par administration dont il faut de son
duo de la respiration
je crois qu'il faut également être
vraiment une culture de l'évaluation
permanente dit évaluation dit on va
scruter les résultats
est ce qu'une politique était mise en
place elles marchent marchent pas et
pouvoir après ajuster sa marche pas et
d'en passer à autre chose
il faut en tirer les conclusions donc sa
deuxième point important
et puis je crois aussi il faut que tout
ça c'est les partis politiques il faut
sûrement les rénover moi je fais le pari
de la rénovation à l'intérieur des
partis du parti politique je crois assez
peu en réalité
bon il ya des poussées d'acné
effectivement des formations poussées
d'acné mais non mais ce que je dis c'est
con je pense que les partis politiques
doivent se rénover profondément mais que
les français ils sont pas prêts pour
partir à l'aventuré avec voilà des
personnes qui dont il ne pense pas
qu'ils puissent et bien les emmener
forcément au bon endroit où est donc la
nouvelle à nous renault est la nouvelle
et fait partie des poussées d'acné
mais on est le délire démocratie
libérale vous étiez vous faites vous
faisait partie des attractions plateau
je suis un de ceux qui peut dire j'ai
été élu en indépendant oui j'ai été élu
sans l'aide d'un parti j'ai tous les
partis m'ont bien candidat face à moi
j'ai quand même été élu quand vous avez
réintégré partir de mai je me suis mis
en apparenté au groupe effectivement
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
lorsque les gens en fait tu vois aussi
l'authenticité
il vous voit sur le terrain mais c'est
pour ça je crois beaucoup à la preuve
par l'exemple
voilà le travail sur le terrain le
terrain il ya que ce soit d'horreur
alors dans votre livre vous écrivez
c'est pas c'est pas eu une époque de
changements mais un changement d'époque
vous avez l'impression que vous faites
quand je dis vous c'est des partis
politiques quels qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs ont pris la mesure du
changement de la société
bon c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'ai
écrit ce livre parce qu'en fait je pense
que les partis globalement n'ont pas
pris vraiment en compte à la fois ce qui
se passe dans le monde autour de nous je
me rappelle un échange il ya pas très
longtemps et pierre joxe qui me disaient
mais en fait en politique les réseaux
politiques n'ont pas pris suffisamment
leurs responsabilités pour expliquer
tous les changements qui est autour de
nous dans le monde en fait et comment on
devait évoluer et prendre en compte ces
changements est en fait tous en train de
muter à la fois le travail l'entreprise
en même temps les organisations
existantes les partis politiques et donc
comment on doit faire pour anticiper
cela est pas été pompier et on ne sommes
pas contrairement à ce que l histoire
des pyromanes
mais on ne donne pas d'être en
permanence des pompiers
deux de ces difficultés qui peuvent
surgir en ce moment je traite un dossier
pendant celui entre les taxis et hubert
dans la médiation que je mène mais on
voit bien que sur ce dossier
sur ce dossier il ya eu des mutations
numérique qui percute une profession
existante et il n'y a pas eu
suffisamment d'anticipation pour agir
vraiment en amont et donc on voit que
les partis politiques qui n'ont pas
suffisamment réfléchi est et qu'il y ait
des mouvements qui émergent que ce soit
nos citoyens que ce soit bleu blanc
zèbres avec alexandre jardin
que ce soit le mouvement de pouria
amirshahi un mouvement commun ou bien
d'autres encore et bien c'est bien parce
que ça percute les partis politiques ça
les bouscule un peu et puis ça leur ça
leur permet aussi d'évoluer parce que si
on attendrait que les partis politiques
évoluent paru même on pourrais je pense
attendre longtemps et je crois qu'il
faut justement qu'ils sortent un peu de
cette ère de la glaciation qu'ils
aillent de l'avant qui prennent des
risques aussi et qu'il dit surtout ils
veulent aller quelles sociétés veulent
construire
qu'est ce que la france de demain ça qui
est important alors pour répondre donc
un autre internaute déjà il ya un verrou
essentiel qu'il faut faire sauter c'est
celui du magma européens de l'union
européenne la commission européenne
parce que nos lois françaises c'est ni
plus du manque de transposition de ce
que l'union européenne nous impose le
taffetas c'est quoi ça entre nous mais
non mais c'est il faut redonner la
souveraineté déjà aux nations en
elle-même en faisant sauter ce verrou
européen ça va permettre de redonner aux
nations et à l'état sa souveraineté
économique sa souveraineté financière sa
souveraineté juridique des frontières
également qui sont nécessaires on voit
maintenant que certains pays les
remettre en place
et tant mieux d'ailleurs monsieur
hollande après les attentats aedian a
peut-être pensé
un art contrôler nos frontières pour
l'instant passe comme une lettre à la
poste
donc en faisant sauter ce verrou de
l'union européenne
les poires on doit pouvoir être donné au
gouvernement à l'état vous parlez de
votre livre c'est très bien mais des
livres on en voit passer tous les jours
on a entendu le changement c'est
maintenant dans ton du discours du
bourget nombreux quelque chose c'est
encore le résumé ils auront finalement
les français sont défiants effectivement
vis-à-vis de l'idée républicaine et du
front national c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire puisque finalement ya dans le
sondage de cette semaine
61% des français qui peuvent que vous
êtes encore un danger donc son site
défiant des amis de vous offrir aussi la
caste politico-médiatique
qu'est-ce-qui qui voit si vous avez des
plateaux télé on voit florian philippot
tous les matins aliot qui nous ont
jamais cette image ici aussi
oui non non non vous exprimer mais quand
même on peut se voir quand quand nos
adversaires n'ont de cesse de nous
couper en attendant c'est quand même la
seule personne les sondages d'ailleurs
l'ont clairement dit comme quoi marine
le pen et rama yade la rage rama yade et
rama yade crûment du tram à rama yade
l'a d'ailleurs dit que seule marine le
pen avait au moins un discours de vérité
alors ça c'est quand même symbolique
maintenant même nos adversaires le
reconnaissent alors aller en ce sens
reconnaissez-le et arrêter d'avoir ses
oeillères devant les arrête le poème
c'est que vous êtes dans une forme de
caricature permanente 30 quand vous
parlez des noms célèbres et c'est le
réalisme c'est la facilité c'est à dire
que je voudrais une période difficile il
ya des lourdais janvier concrète et très
arrêtée du cac40 démarre entre les
encadrements cadre médiatique et c'est
pour ça que je pense vous êtes un
instrument du système en fin de compte
le front national aujourd'hui et vous
voulez pas au contraire de songer à vous
en nourrice et est donc d'ailleurs vous
vous nourrissez de la défiance et vous
vous nourrissez justement peut-être des
difficultés et le jour où le front
national disparaîtra c'est justement
sans doute que la france sera plus
prospère et beaucoup de problèmes seront
réglés parce qu'en fait vous vous
nourrissez cela en permanence en fait
vous avez toujours dans le pessimisme
c'est faux vous êtes natura reprenez des
municipalités et la france et je relise
est une
être delory forte en fait qui équipe un
jeune résident qui était fusillé la
citadelle de besançon à l'âge de 15 ans
et il disait moi ce que je veux là les
dernières lettres qui là qu'il a rédigée
avant de mourir il avait 15 ans ce n'est
pas d'une france justement orgueilleuse
c'est une france prospère où on retrouve
le bonheur est en fait en ces quelques
mots ça résume tout et je crois que
c'est ce qu'il faut retrouver et pour
retrouver cela en fait il faut savoir
faire ensemble faire société
et je crois que dans les débats
politiques bon il ya plein de clivages
et c'est normal ces clivages
ils sont importants mais en même temps
il faut cesser de caricaturer en
permanence vous pouvez pas dire par
exemple les frontières aujourd'hui ça
sert à rien rien à notre police est car
entre gendarmerie
nos militants écolos sur la primaire des
français est ce que c'est vraiment un
projet abouti c'est à dire que vous
voulez porter tel temps serait candidat
ou est ce que c'est un moyen d'alimenter
le débat
non c'est un projet qui quitte en train
de monter puisque aujourd'hui je suis
pas regarder ce matin mais on doit être
à plus de soixante dix mille signatures
en en quinze jours trois semaines
simplement donc j'ai c'est un cetain
déjà un très très beau succès la
primaire des français est la conséquence
directe de la loi qui a été que vous
avez voté en catimini au moment de
pâques sur la réforme de l'élection
présidentielle et là c'est clairement ça
nous a fortement énervé et c'est pour ça
que les six mouvements que composent la
primaire des françaises bleu blanc est
bon cap 21 le pacte civil la transition
et nous citoyens très rapidement dans
les dans les jours qui ont su qui ont
suivi
on s'est réunis et on a dit non c'est
pas possible
leichel ils se foutent purement et
simplement de nous quoi parce que c'est
effectivement bloqué totalement le
totalement le système et en particulier
au niveau médiatique je suis je n'ai pas
d'avis parce que c'est extrêmement
difficile pour vous les périodes des
périodes électorales sera extrêmement
difficile pour vous puisque vous êtes en
tout le temps en train de compter les
secondes se dit mariza et des autres et
là j'ai fait aussi des parcours par
contre en ce en ce qui concerne le les
parrainages
là c'est un proprement c'est un scandale
parce que à partir du monde à partir du
moment où sa partenaire moment où les
maires et des adjoints des conseillers
régionaux départementaux doivent
eux-mêmes envoyer leur parrainage au
conseil constitutionnel les partis et
des petits partis en particulier n'ont
plus aucune possibilité de convaincre
alors dit justement aux téléspectateurs
que effectivement la grande primaire
aura lieu le 20 et 27 novembre pour les
minutes minutes de pub mais tout
simplement parce que les français auront
la parole pourront désigner le candidat
de la droite et du centre
et c'est vrai que et bien c'est quelque
chose de très nouveau pour nous mais
nous souhaitons aller au contact
continuer à y aller
et dire que et bien le candidat qui sera
choisi sera aussi leur candidat et ça
évitera on espère avec lui nous avons
une présidente qui a une ligne qui est
tracée depuis déjà de nombreuses années
le programme évolue nous nous avons un
capitaine
on n'a pas à françois hollande qui est
président candidat on sait pas trop ce
sera monsieur macro monsieur valls c'est
encore un magma
on n'aura pas de candidat
ce sera le test d'un autre débat un mot
pour pasqua le thème de l'émission fut
aussi françois hollande et où la gauche
c'est une bonne idée pour les soutenir
bon je ne suis pas sorti si pas cette
initiative et où la gauche on s'aime on
admire le clarifier les choses pourquoi
pas mais en fait je pense que c'est bien
de faire est le moment d inventaire
parler de ce qui était fait et c est ce
qui est mieux c'est le moment de
l'invention s'est en fait passé des
inventaires à la mention c'est quand
même toujours mieux et donc je pense
qu'il faut plutôt débattre de ce que
l'on veut pour la france aujourd'hui et
demain que de s'intéresser à voir ce que
on a fait il ya cinq ans
merci merci à tous d'avoir accepté ce
débat qui lasse très vite la semaine
prochaine nous vous proposerons une
émission spéciale bourgogne franche
comté émission spéciale consacrée à la
politique du conseil régional en matière
de transport merci de votre attention
vers 6h lisbonne après midi